what's going on what's going on welcome
in welcome everybody to another edition
of Market takes I know you could have
been anywhere in the world but you're
here with me and I appreciate that I'm
your host Dion Robert Bowen thanks for
tuning in to mark it takes we are
talking about the three most important
things you need to be watching out for
this week and it is a big big week of
earnings uh big Tech lots of the market
leaders reporting but of course we're
going to talk you through what's going
on we've got earnings reports from meta
Microsoft alphabet snap I'm talking 3M
Verizon eBay Chipotle Intel Ford we're
not going to talk about all those we're
going to tell you which ones are really
going to be the most impactful or have
the biggest impact on what's going on
with the market this week we're also
going to talk through the FED meeting
the fomc meets this week and they'll
give us their decision on Wednesday and
we're going to talk about the second
quarter U.S GDP report that could really
move markets in a big way that's out on
Thursday so first things first we're
talking through big Tech and the
earnings that we are expecting to see
this week want to put a charter up here
on your screen to just show you what
we're looking at in terms of the market
performance now that green line you see
up there on your screen that's meta
formerly Facebook really leading things
up over 136 percent so far year to date
Microsoft also about 44 year-to-date
alphabet up more than 35 so all really
leading and doing a lot more in terms of
returns than the overall s p the s p up
about 20 percent a little less than that
about 19.6 so far this year but you see
the leadership has all come from Big
Tech everything else is kind of holding
the S P 500 down and the overall returns
have been pretty indicative of what we
have seen from Big Tech so as those
companies come out and Report earnings
this week they're going to be really
very highly watched because of just how
much they have outperformed and led the
market and that has really happened all
year we have seen the NASDAQ up big it's
up 35 while the Dow only up about six
percent S P 500 right in between them
about 19 percent and so that number
you're seeing right there that red line
the s p doesn't look like much when
you're comparing to those other big Tech
names that have reported but we will
hear from them this week and if their
earnings disappoint well this big rally
that we've seen that's got the S P 500
up 20 year-to-date could be in danger
and this chart really just illustrating
the importance of big Tech in that rally
and we're gonna get those readings this
week Tesla Netflix last week they really
disappointed um in terms of guidance
going forward and we saw the reaction
the NASDAQ was down two and a half
percent on Thursday and then Friday we
saw more losses on the NASDAQ on those
Techs on those on the tech side the
NASDAQ we know is the tech heavy index
really we've seen struggles the taoists
continue to do well up 10 straight days
on Friday up right now for the 11th
straight day this would be the longest
streak since February of 2017 if the Dow
ends higher today but like I just showed
you the Dow is only up six percent year
to date it really is all about those
Tech names the earnings that we see this
week could stop the rally in its tracks
because we are expecting or analysts are
expecting a nine percent decline in
earning based on what we've seen in
earnings so far that would be the third
straight negative quarter for earnings
and it would be the most negative
quarter for earnings since Q2 of 2020.
so going back three years since we've
had earnings this negative and it's
really hard for a rally of 20 to
continue where you've already got price
to earnings ratios stretch which is the
historical measure of
how much companies stock prices versus
what they're actually selling versus
what they're actually earning right so
the stock price compared to the earnings
that a company is getting that's that p
e ratio and it's pretty high right now
above both the five and ten year Trends
on the S P 500 the Dow and the NASDAQ so
this really could be a big week in terms
of those earnings that we get
particularly from those big companies
meta Microsoft alphabet those are the
big Tech names the big Tech leaders
you're going to want to watch for those
all three of those are out this week
also snap also Intel have outperformed
but those are the three big ones you
want to watch next up we're going to
talk about the FED decision that's
almost been lost in all this earnings
talk but the FED is coming out jpal AKA
JP AKA J pow AKA JP money is going to be
talking to us on Wednesday afternoon
we'll be right here for Market takes
breaking down everything the chairman
said didn't say all that let's put a
chart up here on your screen really fast
to just show you where we are in terms
of the environment now we are there on
the right you see earnings up about
right around five percent between five
and five point two five percent that is
about as high as we've been in the last
20 years you see the last time uh rates
were this high was back in 2008 and we
all know what happened in 2008 uh so
when rates get this High usually the
economy starts to get a little shaky the
FED is hoping to slow things down kind
of cool things off and not have sort of
those similar recession results that we
had seen there but again this chart just
illustrating where we are right now in
terms of the rates environment and we
are at a very high level the FED is at
restrictive territory it seems but the
big question is is what is Jay Powell
going to say about that and that's going
to determine whether we get a hawkish
hike or a dovish hike listen the market
is already pricing in a rate hike of 25
basis points at this fed meeting in fact
when you look at the FED funds Futures
Market it's showing a 99.8 likelihood as
of this morning as of right now when
we're talking here uh that the FED is
going to hike so the market is saying
that's a foregone conclusion what
matters is what Jay Powell says at that
meeting whether he says you you know
what there's more to do we think there
will be more rate hikes the FED at its
last meeting projected two more rate
hikes this year if they do this one now
the big question is are they going to do
another one I got a hike in September
maybe November and what are they going
to say to get the market ready for that
or are they going to say Hey you know we
think we've done enough we think we need
to pump the brakes on pumping the brakes
and no more rate hikes anymore and so
watch out for words like hold or we've
done enough or policy is restrictive
enough that's going to determine whether
it's a dovish or hawkish rate hike and
the market is going to have a strong
reaction to that one way or another so
you're going to want to watch that fed
meeting you want to be you're going to
want to be with us here on Market takes
as we break that down at 4 pm Eastern on
Wednesday and you'll want to be here you
won't want to be anywhere else last
thing we've got coming this week is
second quarter GDP and that's big
because of what this could really lock
in what I've termed soft Landing Summer
and I want to tell you why so we're
going to put a few charts up here on
your screen to just kind of show you
what we're looking for in terms of what
we've been looking at in terms the data
first things first the U.S retail sales
report and we talked about this a couple
weeks ago when this report came out this
is the year-over-year change and you see
it just coming down there to where it's
still positive it's still up higher than
it was the year before but it's much
lower it's under two percent the last
reading we got in June was one and a
half percent and that just illustrating
again you saw retail sales increases
were very high people were getting a lot
more money that's not taking into
account inflation and it's come down a
lot another chart I want to put up here
is the increase in job support though
that non-farm payrolls report this is
the increase in jobs we've seen uh month
over month and so each month you've seen
an increase in the number of jobs but
that increases slowing down last couple
months what we saw in June and then what
we saw in April were some of the lowest
we've seen since early 2021 in terms of
jobs added so this chart again just
illustrating that cool down that
deceleration the slowing down and now I
want to throw the big one the most
important chart in terms of data and
that's that CPI inflation report want to
put that up there on your screen and you
see just that very clear pattern of
deceleration slow down now this good
illustrator this chart here illustrates
what we have seen in terms of the
overall data set coming down and
declining and illustrating like I said
just what I've called Soft Landing
someone that's because the things are
coming down but they're still staying
positive still seeing an increase you're
still seeing good positive numbers up
there on your screen but they're slower
they're lower closer the fed's two
percent inflation goal and if we see Q2
GDP come in as expected which is 1.7
percent that could really lock this in
again another report showing that hey
for the second quarter growth was
positive it was solid but it wasn't too
strong it wasn't too hot it wasn't
inflationary it was just showing the US
is chugging along growing as the FED
wants to see so that's really what we're
looking for in this week and you'll want
to look out for all those things
earnings you want to watch the fed and
you'll want to watch that Q2 GDP number
be right here for Market takes at 4 pm
on Wednesday you wouldn't want to be
anywhere else and listen that's going to
do it for us I am Dion Robert Bowen
reporter at the Wall Street Journal
thanks so much for being with us and we
hope you'll come back and do it with us
next time